every year people arrive at base camp in
nepal to fulfill a long life dream to
climb the highest peak in the world
mount everest
what was once only achievable by elite
mountaineers has now become accessible
to thousands of tourists and climbers
from around the world and that's part of
the problem human activity coupled with
global warming is having a detrimental
effect on everest's ecosystem making the
ascent unsafe
at an altitude of 5
364 metres above sea level base camp
lies on the kumbu glacier
scientists are warning the glaciers
melting at an alarming rate by as much
as one meter every year
especially melting its issue of melting
glacier and the crevasses
so a bit worrying that maybe in 10 years
you know there'll be no more glacier and
crevasses
climbers and sherpas say cracks and
crevices appear overnight and it's
putting their lives at risk melted ice
is also causing rock falls and can
trigger avalanches in the himalayas
in an attempt to protect the natural
environment the nepalese government has
decided to move everest's base camp to a
new location and that's roughly
meters lower where there's no year-round
ice
certainly this is the right time to
advocate and raise the boys together and
not only talk always the boys we need to
sort it out so
yeah of course the best ham has been
very congested and every year but
definitely there are more than 1500
people so the human waste has been
polluted
around 4 000 liters of urine is dumped
at base camp every day and because
climbers spend weeks on the peak
adjusting to the altitude they generate
several kilos of waste most of which is
left on the mountain from fuel use for
cooking and heating to empty oxygen
cylinders and abandoned camping
equipment
all this has created a moral and
environmental debate on the human
obsession to scale the tallest mountain
in the world
al jazeera
so extreme floods melting glasses
extreme heat all symptoms of a warmer
world according to climate scientists
danish mustafa is a professor in
critical geography at king's college
london uh he can take this on with us
danish so this situation in everest and
everything else that we've been
reporting on in this last hour all
symptoms of the broader problem of
global warming and its impacts affecting
glaciers and changing the climate around
the world
i think that uh these are certainly uh
worrying uh some uh symptoms
and i think a bigger problem is a male
adjustment to these symptoms
i think that
the public has a bit of a
problematic understanding of science
science almost never can give you uh
certainties what it can give you is
odds
and
climate science can tell us that we are
95 confidence 99 confident that all the
averages that were in the past all the
normal conditions that we were used to
in the past are not going to hold into
the future
so if you're getting unprecedented
floods in bangladesh or in china or if
you're getting glacial melt in the high
himalayas
i think it is basically symptomatic that
whatever we are used to in the past is
not going to continue into the future
right it's doubly
yeah i was just going to say that the
trend is the thing and the trend is
gaining momentum and the trend is is
looking quite frightening
trend is frightening but equally i would
caution about uh
uh
we we need longer term uh trends longer
term data if you will we certainly uh
the data for the past 10 15 years
is certainly worrying
and coupled with our understanding of
the climate dynamics uh we we can
certainly be fairly confident that in
fact we are seeing symptoms of that
but the bigger issue is what to do about
it right
global warming is there and what to do
about it is at the moment what we see in
bangladesh or in india or in china or in
many other parts of the world is as if
following a certain developmental
trajectory of building infrastructure
occupation of flood zones uh flood
plains uh
uh promotion of uh
uh
of river engineering fighting against
the rivers those are sort of 19th
century early 20th century european
tropes uh which are being replicated at
the moment in the global south with
potentially catastrophic consequences
you say we need longer term data we need
to focus on adaptation i think is what
you're saying
given everything else that's going on in
the world you know the political
polarization the war on ukraine and so
forth are we just taking our eye off
perhaps the biggest threat of all
we are absolutely taking our eye off the
ball and i don't even know if we
necessarily had our eye on there
it just seems like there's a whole set
of political economic uh uh
compulsions or ideologies which are
which are driving driving societies for
example china china more more concrete
in the first 20 years of the 21st
century than the united states did in
the entire 20th century
following a certain developmental model
equally building of dams building of
roads
trying to build levees trying to hem in
uh rivers the size of uh
brahmaputra is going to have the kind of
consequences that we're seeing at the
moment floods are not bad in themselves
i mean after all human civilization
emerged and and developed some of the
most ancient civilizations emerged and
developed along along flood plains the
point is that when we stop living with
floods and for the past
150 years
we have changed our
paradigm of floods from living with
floods towards fighting floods and when
you fight floods you're going to lose
and this is another example of how we
have lost so there's a fundamental
paradigmatic reevaluation that needs to
take place and i'm afraid that that sort
of re-evaluation in the face of climate
change is simply not happening okay uh
finally
and briefly if you would it's not any
extreme weather events that we're
talking about here it's also how you
know vegetation belts are moving further
northwards
as far as the northern hemisphere is
concerned and
the implications that has on you know
migrations of animals and so forth and
indeed food production
indeed uh i think the evidence is
overwhelming and you basically deny that
evidence at your own peril
uh but turns out that
politicians
uh businesses and others uh tend to have
a more uh sort of a monthly weekly uh
sort of a time horizon whereas climate
change demands uh a more longer term
time horizon and thinking more
strategically and your society at
present is just not geared towards
thinking strategically it is it keeps
thinking tactically in short time steps
and looking for immediate return uh with
the sorts of consequences that you're
observing dan it's great to get your
perspective and expertise appreciate
that danish mustafa talking to us there
you're welcome